[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
وزير الخارجيه السعودي في كييف يلتقي
زيلينسكي ودعوه للحل السلمي ومساعدات الى
اوكرانيا
اتفاق خفض التصعيد في العقبات تخلله عمليه
تقتل مستوطنين وهجمات الانتقاميه في بلده
حواره في نابلس
لاول مره منذ عام 2011 وزير خارجيه مصر في
دمشق غدا وقرار بتسريع عوده العلاقه
تقرير امريكي الرسمي يؤكد ان كورونا تسرب
من مختبر من خلال حادث وليس برنامجا
عسكريا
[موسيقى]
اسعدت موقوتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
البدايه من كييف حيث التقى الرئيس
الاوكراني بوزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان واكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
لذيلينسكي ان المملكه تبدل كل جهود لتخفيض
معاناه الشعب الاوكراني وقال ان المملكه
قدمت حزمتين من المساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه
410 ملايين دولار بدوره شكر الرئيس
الاوكراني المملكه على دعمها جهود السلام
في هذا الاطار اكد ان اهتمام سيدي خالد
في الجانب الانساني في اوكرانيا كبير جدا
وقد اتى نتيجه ذلك توجيه القياده بتقديم
حزبتين من المساعدات الانسانيه لاوكرانيا
بمبلغ اجمالي 410 مليون دولار وقد وقعنا
اليوم على اتفاقتين
تؤسس لتسليم هذه
الاعانات ونامل ان تكون
عونا في تخفيف معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في
هذه الازمه الانسانيه ولا شكل المملكه
تبذل كافه الجهود التي من شانها التخفيف
من معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في الداخل
والنازحين في دول الجوار
كذا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على حرص المملكه على حل الازمه
في اوكرانيا بالحوار وشدد على ضروره خفض
التصعيد وحمايه
المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه اللسان في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن السعوديه لان لدينا قناع راسخه
ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون بالحوار
ويجون على طاوله في اطار مبادئ القانون
الدولي والميثاق الامم المتحده واحترام
سياده الدول ولهذا سوف نستمر في العمل مع
جميع الاطراف للبحث عن فرص الوصول الى
هكذا تسويه
كما التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان فور وصوله الى كيف مديره
مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني اندريه في مقر
الرئاسه بالعاصمه وجرس تعرض دهود السعوديه
الراميه الى ايجاد حلول سياسيه للازمه
الاوكرانيه واوجه المساعدات المقدمه من
السعوديه لاوكرانيا وشعبها بهدف التخفيف
من اثار الازمه ووقعت السعوديه مع
اوكرانيا مذكره تفاهم للمشتقات النفطيه
وببرنامجا للعمل الانساني وعلى الصندوق
السعودي للتنميه عن دعم اوكرانيا بالغاز
المسال ومشتقات النفط بمبلغ ثلاثمائه
مليون دولار
ومن جهته قال مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
اندريه لقائه بوزير الخارجيه السعودي قال
ان اوكرانيا والسعوديه لديهما تحد مشترك
بالتعامل مع المسيرات الايرانيه
اود ان اذكركم بان اوكرانيا والسعوديه
لديهما تحديات وخبرات مشتركه نتحدث عن
مسيرات ايرانيه تم تسليمها لبعض المتمردين
ونفذت هجمات على منشات نفطيه في السعوديه
منذ العام الماضي كانت المسيرات الايرانيه
نفسها في حوزه الارهابيين الروس وتقوم
بهجمات على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
الاوكرانيه
قال مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه الرئيس الروسي واثق للغايه من
قدره جيشه على الانتصاب في اوكرانيا
على الاستمرار في الحرب على الرغم من
الخسائر والعيوب التكتيكيه والاضرار
الاقتصاديه وخلال لقاء مع شبكه سي بي اس
اكد مدير المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
نابوتين استخف بعزم الولايات المتحده على
دعم اوكرانيا وانها ستواجه انظارها الى
منطقه اخرى في العالم في نهايه المطاف
اخر اجرت شبكه فوكس نيوز ان 48% يوافقون
على رد بايدن على العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه ويقول 50% ان الولايات المتحده
يجب ان تدعم اوكرانيا ضد الروس طالما ان
الامر يتطلب الفوز ومع تبلور الحمله
الرئاسيه لعام 2004 من المرجح ان يشهد
الجمهوريون تصعيدا في نقاشهم داخل الحزب
حول اوكرانيا حيث شكك حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
في سياسات بايدن قائلا انه ليس من مصلحه
الدوله الدخول في حرب بالوكاله مع الصين
او التورط في امور مثل الاراضي الحدوديه
او شبه جزيره الكنز
[موسيقى]
وبالتزامن مع اصداء الانقسام بشان دعم
اوكرانيا في الولايات المتحده شارك نحو
عشره الاف شخص في احتجاجات في برلين رفضا
لتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه في الحرب مع
روسيا بما شهدت العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
تظاهرات داعيه الى ارساء السلام حيث دعا
منظمون احتجاج المستشار الالماني الى وقف
شحنه الاسلحه لان كل يوم يمر يكلف ما يصل
الى الف روح ويجعل العالم اقرب الى حرب
عالميه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نعود الى زياره وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اليوم ولقائه بالرئيس زيلينسكي
هناك حول الموضوع معنا من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
اهلا بكم معنا السعوديه ستقدم انسانيه الى
اوكرانيا باكثر من 410 ملايين دولار كيف
تقرا زياره وزير الخارجيه السعودي في هذا
التوقيت الى كيف
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته هو تحيه
طيبه امين اوكرانيا هذه الزياره بارزه
اليوكرانيا وكمان السعوديه
موجوده تعامل مثمره بين بلدين
الى هذا هذا الدعم كبير لشعب اوكرانيا
ونحن شاكرون الى هذا المساعده خيريه
ومساعده بتقديم منتجات النفطيه لاوكراني
هذا مهم جدا يعني مناسبه انا اليوم كمان
تقدم تقولي حكومه اوكرانيه
مع السعوديه في عقب وهذا التاسيس برنامج
نفط مقابل حبوب اوكرانيه في مستقبل
ادراك بان موجود البيزنس وخاصه في مجال
الزراعي السعودي
في اوكرانيا
هي تعامل بنجاحه هنا في اوكرانيا في محفظه
هذه الشركه اكثر من 200 الف هكتار من تربه
الزراعيه على وطننا لها اوكرانيا تستطيع
ان تقترحوا بالسعوديه استصلاح طورب
الصحراويه الى التربه الزراعيه خاصه نحن
في خرسون متخصصين في هذا الموضوع يعني
بصفه عمل مجالات للتعامل مع السعوديه هي
كبيره وكمان مهمه بان عموما يزورون
اوكرانيا
سياسيين كبار من الغرب ولكن ليست من
الخليج نعم
كبير ودعم
معنوينيه ولشعب اوكرانيا طيب هذا فيما
يتعلق باهميه هذه الزياره كما تفضلت وهذه
الاستثمارات بين السعوديه واوكرانيا الان
فيما يتعلق بما قاله الوزير بن فرحان عن
استمرار مساء السعوديه لاحلال السلام في
اوكرانيا كيف ترى الدور الذي يمكن ان
تلعبه السعوديه هنا في مساله احلال السلام
في اوكرانيا
بصراحه بصفه عامه انا قليلا متشائما لان
هدفا عند اوكرانيا هذا انسحاب قوات مصالحه
روسيه من اراضي اوكرانيه وللاسف الشديد
نحن نشاهد عند رسالات توجد اي الرغبه
لانسحاب وقواتها من اوكرانيا كما اولا
انسحاب قوات مصالحه روسيه من ارادو
اوكرانيه من الممكن اي مفاوضات نعم طيب
فيما يتعلق كذلك بدور السعوديه دائما
السعوديه موقفها يعني بقي على مسافه واحده
بين روسيا واوكرانيا هل برايك هذا الموقف
الان
يمكن ان يجعل السعوديه تلعب دورا فيما
يتعلق بالوساطه بين الطرفين بين الروس
والاوكرانيين وبينكم اقصد اكيد نحن سوف
نرحب اي اي جهود من السعوديه حول الحل هذه
هنا في اوكرانيا نحن كمان نعرف ان ننتهي
هذا حرب في اقرب وقت واوكرانيا تعني جدا
وخاصه اقتصاديا وعقيد روسيا تدمر واقتصاد
اوكرانيا بشكل كبير ولكن كما قلت
ان ينتهي هذا وهو يرغب المفاوضات ولكن لا
يرغبون السلام للاسف الشديد في اقرب
بان هذه حرب هي سوف تكون طويله ودمويه
للغايه هنا في اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه الوضعيه
يتطور هناك حيث قتل فلسطيني واصيب اكثر من
عشرين اخرين خلال هجوم لمستوطنين على قريه
حواره في نابلس واشاره المصادر الى ان
حصيله الجرحى ارتفعت الى 100 وتعرضت بلدات
وقرى في نابلس منذ عصر اليوم الى هجوم
واسع من المستوطنين والقوات الاسرائيليه
حيث دمر المستوطنون منازل ومنشات ومركبات
للفلسطينيين وادانت رئاسه الفلسطينيه
اعمال المستوطنين وقالت ان هذه الاعمال
تتم بحمايه القوات الاسرائيليه فيما اعلنت
حركه فتح النفير العام ودعت كوادرها الى
التصدي الاعتداءات المستوطنين الى ذلك
اتهم زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه هي
ايرلافيد الموالين لوزير الامن القومي
اثمر
باحراق نابلس من اجل افشال اتفاق العقبه
معنى الان من رام الله مراسلنا خالد
القاسم خالد اهلا بك معنا اخر المعطيات
حول ما يجري في
الحواره خالد يعني هي حواره وقريه عصير
القبليه وبهتا وبورين وزعتره هنالك
تتمركز باعتداءات المستوطنين وبوجود الجيش
الاسرائيلي اضافه الى اعتداءات المستوطنين
من شمال الضفه الغربيه حتى جنوبها في
الخليل هناك اعتداءات على
مركبات المواطنين في بلده حواره احرق
المستوطنون اكثر من عشرين منزلا معظمها
ماهوله بالسكان وكانت هناك نداءات استغاثه
من داخل المنازل الجيش الاسرائيلي وفق
شهود عيان منع سيارات الدفاع المدني
والمسعفين من الوصول الى
المنازل قبل قليل تدخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
بشكل
في حواره وانسحب المستوطنون باتجاه
المستوطنات المحيطه ببلده حوار هذه
الاعتداءات ادت الى مقتل فلسطيني من بلده
الزعتره وهي قريه شبه معزوله عن محيطها
وتقع مباشره على حادث زعتره العسكري هدم
المستوطنون القريه تصدى لهم احد سكانها
اطلقوا الرصاص
باتجاهه اصابته رصاصه في البطن ادت الى
وفاته اكثر من 90 اصابه تعاملت معها طواقم
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني والاصابات بالطعن
بالسكاكين او الضرب بادوات حاده او
الاختلاف جراء استنشاق
هذه الاعتداءات ما تزال مستمره على معظم
الطرقات في الضفه الغربيه وهناك دعوات
شبابيه فلسطينيه للنفير العام للتصدي
بهجمات المستوطنين على الكره الواقعه على
الشارع الرئيسي تحديدا بين مدينتين نابلس
هل صحيح ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يدعم
هؤلاء المستوطنين في اعتداءاتهم على حوار
في نابلس
يعني كان موجودا ولم يتدخل لمنع هذه
الاعتداءات معظم صور المنازل التي كانت
تحترق تظهر فيها جيبات عسكريه اسرائيليه
المستوطنون يمرحون ويسرحون في الشارع
الرئيسي لمدينه
حواره دون الجيش المتواجد اصلا في المنطقه
كل شهود العيان
تحدثوا الينا عبر الهاتف قالوا بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يمنع اعتداءات المستوطنين
بل منع سيارات الدفاع المدني من الوصول
الى المنازل المحترقه لاخماد النيران ومنع
الاسعاف والهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني من نقل
المصابين من داخل بلده حواره او بلده
بورين او عصيره القبليه التي قام عشرات
المستوطنين بينطارها بوابه من الرصاص قبل
حوالي الساعه طيب خالد دعنا نعود الى
خلفيه ما يحدث الاحداث المشتعله تقريبا
منذ العصر في حواره في نابلس بالتحديد لما
يعني هي
هي الاحداث مستمره منذ ايام ولكن اليوم
عندما اقدم مسلح باطلاق النار على
مستوطنين في بلده حواره وارداهما قتيلين
اشتعلت المنطقه وتحديدا كانت فرصه مواتيه
للمستوطنين
للعربده والاعتداء على منازل
الفلسطينيين وتحديدا في بلده حواره وبلده
بورين القريبتين من مستوطنه هاربراخا
ومستوطنه
يتسار هنا بدات
الشراره باعتداء المستوطنين على منازل
المواطنين كما ذكرت لك دون ان يتدخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي او الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي هل
هناك اي تصريحات فلسطينيه من السلطه قبل
قليل ذكرت انه هذه
هذا التصعيد يهدف الى
اتفاق العقبه
هذا التصعيد ادنقت الحكومه الفلسطينيه كما
اذنته الرئاسه الفلسطينيه واعتبرته ارهابا
منظما وعلى المجتمع الدولي التدخل اللي
لازم اعتداءات المستوطنين والتدخل للضغط
على اسرائيل لوقف هذه
الاعتداءات ولكن على ما يبدو هناك ضبط
ميداني قد نشهده غدا او بعد غد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه تهيئه
لانجاح ما تم الاتفاق عليه في مدينه
العقبه رغم التهديدات
بان الاستيطان لن يتوقف في يوم واحد شكرا
جزيلا لك خالد القاسم عبر الهاتف من رام
الله
قبل ذلك ايضا قال رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
في اراضي الضفه الغربيه سيتواصل وفق
الجداول المحدده وذلك بعد ساعات قليله من
ختام اجتماع العقبه بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وكان مسؤول اسرائيلي اشار
في وقت سابق لانه لن يكون هناك تغيير على
خطط بناء تسعه الاف وخمسمائه وحده
اصطداميه
وكان اجتماع العقبه اختتم اليوم اذا بين
مسؤولين اسرائيليين وفلسطينيين ومصريين
واردنيين وامريكيين لبحث خفض التصعيد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وحسب وكاله الانباء
الاردنيه فقد تم التاكد او التاكيد على
ضروره الالتزام بخفض التصعيد على الارض
ومنع المزيد من العنف وهو ما يبدو انه
فاشل هذه الليله كما اكد المجتمعون على
اهميه الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي في القدس
دون تغيير كما اكدت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه الاستعداد لوقف
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى
سته اشهر كما اتفق المشاركون على الاجتماع
مجددا في شرم الشيخ في شهر مارس المقبل
لتحقيق اهداف اجتماع العقبه
الى ذلك رحبت الولايات المتحده باتفاق
العقبه واقل مستشار الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض ان امريكا تثمن اتفاق خفض التصعيد
واشار صوليبا ان هذا الاجتماع يعد نقطه
بدايه ومن المهم استكمال البناء عليه خلال
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله حتى يتم التوصل
الى سلام واستقرارا للفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين على حد سواء
لكن ليست كل ردود الافعال كانت مرحبه
باتفاق العقبه مشاهدينا فمثلا قال وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمر بن جبير ان
ما تم الاتفاق عليه في الاردن سيبقى في
الاردن واضافها بن جبير ان التفاهمات قمه
العقبه لن تحدث واتفق زعيم وانتقد زعيم
المعارضه الاسرائيليه
وقال ان الحكومه ترسل وفدا للعقبه للتواصل
الى اتفاق ثم يعارضها كبار الوزراء واصفا
الحكومه بالفوضى الخطيره اما حركه حماس
فهاجمت الاجتماع وقالت انه بلا قيمه ولن
يغير شيئا
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
العمليه او العمله الايرانيه تلامس قاعا
جديدا والدولار الواحد يسجل اكثر من 600
الف ريال
مرحبا بكم من جديد قناه وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه اين الوزير سامح شكري سيزور غدا
العاصمه السوريه دمشق في زياره هي الاولى
لوزير خارجيه مصري لسوريا منذ 2011 وقالت
الخارجيه المصريه ان شكري سيزور ايضا
تركيا وذلك لنقل تضامن مصر بعد الزلزال
الذي ضربت دولتين
هذا وقالت مصادره مصريه للعربيه ان
القاهره تعمل على اعاده ترتيب العلاقات مع
الجانب السوري واتخذت قرارا بتوسيع
العلاقات مع سوريا بشكل اكبر وتدريجي
واشارت الى ان زياره وزير الخارجيه مصر
لدمشق تهدف لتنسيق التعاون في ملفات عده
ابرزها الامن وتحدثت المصادر عن ان
القاهره سترسل وفودا الى دمشق الفتره
المقبله لتوسيع قاعده الزيارات بينهما
اضافت المصادر ان القاهره تحاول اقناع
الولايات المتحده بتخفيف العقوبات عن
سوريا
قبل ذلك قالت الرئاسه السوريه ان الرئيس
بشار الاسد استقبل في دمشق وفدا من
الاتحاد البرلماني العربي للتعبير عن
التضامن مع دمشق بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب البلاد مؤخرا اضافه رئاسه السوريه ان
الوفد ضم رئيس الاتحاد رئيس مجلس النواب
العراقي محمد الحلبوسي ورؤساء مجلس النواب
في الامارات والاردن وفلسطين وليبيا ومصر
اضافه الى رؤساء وفدي سلطنه عمان ولبنان
والامين العامل الاتحادي البرلماني العرب
معنى من القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد عضو
لجنه شؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان المصري
سابقا ومستشار المركز الاهرام اهلا بك
معنا دكتور عماد زياره الوزير شكري هي اول
زياره كما ذكرت لوزير خارجيه المصري منذ
2011 الى دمشق هل هذا مؤشر على ان
العلاقات العربيه مع سوريا ستعود الى سابق
عهدها قبل 2011 قبل الثوره السوريه
يعني
اللي انا عايز اقوله في البدايه انه
زياره وزير الخارجيه المصري جاءت بعد
زياره
البرلمان
العرب نعم رئيس البرلمان مع عدد من رؤساء
البرلمانات من بينهم مصر
وبالتالي يبدو لي واضحا ان هناك خطوات
متفق عليها يعني هذه الخطوه يعني لازم
اقول لحضرتك انه بدايه انا كنت عضو في
مجلس نواب مصر 2012 واللي خد القرار بقطع
العلاقات البرلمانيه ثم العلاقات التونسيه
الاخوان يعني البرلمان الاخوان ثم محمد
مرسي خذ قرار بقطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
بعد
2014 بدات الامور يعني تكون اكثر هدوءا
لكن اللي انا عايز اقوله انه
كون ان هذه الزياره تاتي بعد زياره الوفد
البرلماني معناها ان هناك ايادي
هي ممدوده ومفتوحه على جانب المصري طبعا
انفتاح على سوريا بالتنسيق مع الدول
العربيه وانفتاح على تركيا واستغلال احداث
الزلزال في اتخاذه كمبرر
يعني قد يعترض معترض دكتور عماد ويقول
يعني انه منذ 2011 والاحداث في سوريا
والازمه السوريه ماذا عن الذين ماتوا في
هذه الازمه في سوريا ماذا عن الذين هجروا
كل هذه المعاناه هؤلاء الملايين الذين
يعني عانوا من هذا الوضع الان يعود الوضع
الى سابق عهده بشكل عادي يعني انه هذا
امام الامر الواقع يعني عوده العلاقات مع
النظام السوري بهذا الشكل
لا اعتقد على الاطلاق لان النظام السوري
لم يعد هو النظام السوري اللي قبل 2011 لم
يعد على مستوى القوه ولا على مستوى
الشعبيه ولا مستوى العلاقات يعني علاقته
محدوده بايران وروسيا حتى العلاقات مع
تركيا فيها مشكله العلاقات مع دول عربيه
فيها مشكله العقد مع الامريكان فيها مشكله
كبيره وفي عقوبات وفي حصار النقطه
الاساسيه هنا انه صح حضرتك بتقول ان في
عشرات الالاف دفعوا حياتهم وكان في تعذيب
اتصور انه يكون النظام السوري خد درس بانه
سياساته لم تعد صالحه وان السياساتهم
البلد وادت الى سقوط عشرات الالاف وادت
الى تمزق البلد وانقسامه
وتدخلوا يعانون الامرين يعني بسبب هذه
الاحداث طيب ولكن كما تفضلت واضح انه هناك
راي عربي يذهب الى اعاده العلاقات مع دمشق
تدريجيا
في مقابل ماذا لماذا دكتور عماد لماذا
الان يعني لماذا يعني بعد كل يعني القطيعه
كان هناك قطيعه يعني مع نظام السوري طوال
هذه السنوات لماذا الان هناك هذا الراي
العربي الان لاعاده العلاقه مع دمشق
اتصور انه انه انه
التجربه اللي مع العراق يعني تجربه كانت
سابقه يعني العراق غزل كويت سنه 90 وكان
في مشاكل وكذا واستمرت لكن وايران اكتسحت
العراق يعني سيطرت على مفاصل الدوله
العراقيه لما حصل الانفتاح العربي مع رئيس
الوزراء السابق
بداوا يتنفسوا ويلاقوا مخرج بدليل ان رئيس
البرلمان العراقي هو رئيس البرلمان العربي
وهو راح وهو اللي خد الخطوه اتصور ان هناك
رؤيه بتقول انه عشر سنين من القتل والدمار
والتشتيت لم تحقق مصلحه اي طرف لا النظام
السوري لا يسيطر على الاراضي بالكامل
المعارضه
منقسمه وممزقه والشعب يعاني اتصور ان في
ابروش او مقترب مشابه اللي تم مع العراق
النهارده لما عملت مع العراق النفوس
الايراني بيتراجع تدريجيا
ايران ممسكه بمفاصل الدوله السوريه
اتصور هذه الخطوه العربيه هتبقى فيها
مصلحه كبرى لسوريا المهم نقطه رئيسيه عايز
اركز عليها ان يستقبل النظام السوري هذا
الانفتاح العربي
بواقعيه وموضوعيه يعني
فكره انه العرب عادوا الينا وسوريا مش
عارف ايه وسوريا القوميه وسوريا العروبه
هذا الخطاب اتصور انه لابد ان ينتهي ويسمي
هذه الخطوه من جانب البرلمان العربي
ويتجاوب وهيبقى في اتصالات يصل فيها
لتوافقات على غرار ما تم مع العراق اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا دكتور عماد جاد كنت معنا من
القاهره
[موسيقى]
الازمات في ايران منذ العام الماضي لا
تزال مستمره فالاحتجاجات والغضب يتعاظمان
والازمه الاقتصاديه تزداد حده اليوم
انخفضت العمله الايرانيه الى مستوى قياسي
جديد مقابل الدولار وتبادل المتعاملون
الريال الايرانيه عند اكثر من 600 الف
ريال للدولار الواحد يذكر انه تم تداول
العمله الايرانيه عند مستوى 32 الف ريال
للدولار في وقت الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015
الذي اسفر عن رفع العقوبات الدوليه عن
طهران مقابل فرض قيود شديده على البرنامج
النووي وفق ما نقلته وكاله
افاد مركز الاحصاء الايراني الاسبوع
الماضي فان معدل التضخم بلغ اكثر من 53%
في شهر يناير الماضي
[موسيقى]
اكد عبد الرحيم ده قالوه القائد الثاني
بقوات الدعم السريع بالسودان ان حدوث
اشتباك مع الجيش هو امر مستحيل ونقل بيان
للقوات الدعم السريع عن دقله قوله ان
القوات مع مبدا الجيش الواحد واصلاح
المؤسسات العسكريه واضاف ان قوات الدعم
السريع تقف مع اراده وتطلعات الشعب
السوداني مشيرا الى استمرارها بدعم
الاتفاق ايطالي
توترات كانت خفيه بين رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
ونائبه الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو اتضحت عبر
مخاطبات علنيه بينهما بحسب مصادر العربيه
فان الخلافات سببها تباين المواقف
السياسيه واتهام البرهان لنائبه باستغلال
منصبه لتحركات خارجيه سريه
قبل فتره كان الرجلان قادرين على اخفاء
خلافاتهما والجلوس مع بعضهما لتخفيف
التوتر اما الان لم يعد الامر كذلك لجا
رئيسه مجلس السياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو الى ايصال
الرسائل لبعضهم في العلن حده وصل اليها
الاثنان بعد تباعد المواقف السياسيه
بينهما بشان تشكيل الحكومه ثم ما تسرب من
اتهام البرهان لنائبه باستغلال منصبه
السيادي لاجراء تحركات داخليه وخارجيه
سريه
والمهم جدا نحن كعسكرين بهمنا والدمج قوات
الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه
الفيصل بيننا وبين الحل الحسيمه قد وضع
الاتفاق الاطار اساسا متينا للمبادئ
الرئيسيه فهذا الاتفاق حزمه واحده يجب ان
تنفذ كلها دون تجزئه
غير ان اللافته بان الحرب بالكلاميه
الاخيره لم تعد بين البرهان وحميتي انما
دخل فيها عضوان مجلس السياده شمس الدين
كباشي وياسر العطاء
حديثه محترمه بها جيشان وهما اللذان صمت
لفتره طويله ما فسر انهما ليس على وفاق مع
قائدهما واللافت ايضا ان الرسائل كانت تصل
الى دلل من الولايات وفي مناسبات اجتماعيه
ليست سياسيه هو خلاف نتيجه للتقاطع الفهم
لدفاع الايطالي
وخلاف بالنسبه للمستقبل السياسي للرجلين
لذلك جاء هذا الخلاف
وقوه سياسيه
تحاول ان تغازل
المركزين ما يتضح في هذا الخلاف هو تقارب
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي مع حميتي
ودفاع ناشطين عنه في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في وقت يبدو الطرف الاخر من
القوى السياسيه اقرب للبرهان وتنشط ايضا
حمله الدفاع عنه لا يمكن ان نصدر ادانا
لخطاب للخطاب الذي قدمه قائد الدعم السريع
والتزم فيه بكل ما جاء في الاتفاق الاطاري
لا يمكن ان نحول هذه الخطاب
لادانه رغم ان بضعه امتار فقط تفصل مكتب
رئيس مجلس السياده النائبه داخل القصر
الجمهوري الا ان الحوار بينهما بات برسائل
مشفره في العلن فهل يمضي الفطور بينهما ام
يجلسان لتخفيف التوتر لنعقوبه العربيه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
تحدثت صحيفه وسط جورنال عن تقرير امريكي
رسمي يشير الى ان فيروس كورونا تسرب من
مختبر في الصين كما استبعد التقرير
الامريكي ان يكون تسرب كورونا نتيجه
برنامج عسكري بيولوجي صيني وقالت الصحيفه
ان المسؤولين الامريكيين رفضوا الادلاء
بتصريحات علنيه بشان التقييمات الجديده
التي وصلت اليها عدد من الوكالات
الفيدراليه
معنا عبر زوم من لندن دكتور احمد سلمان
استاذ علم المناعه في تطوير اللقاحات في
معهد ادوارد جينر مرحبا بك معنا دكتور
احمد اذا هذا التقرير لاستخبارات الامريكي
السري يخلص الى ان فيروس كورونا تسرب من
مختبر في وهران الصينيه ما الذي يعني هذا
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك والساده المشاهدين هو
طبعا كان للتوضيح كان هناك احتمالين لتسرب
الفيروس او ظهور فيروس كورونا المستجد
لاحتمال الاول انه ظهر وانتقل للناس عن
طريقه طبيعيه من الناس خارج يعني المعامل
وخارج الابحاث سواء عن طريق الاكل وكانت
الفرضيه الاخرى انه تسرب من معمل ولكن
الشيء المؤكد بنسبه كبيره جدا يعني تقترب
لنسبه مئه في المئه ان الفيروس لم يتم
تصنيعه في المعمل مهم جدا فضيحه هذه
النقطه وذلك بناء على المعلومات العلميه
وتعامل كل العلماء في العالم مع الفيروس
ولكن هنا سؤال اذا كان لم يصنع في المختبر
دكتور احمد كيف وجد هذا الفيروس يعني هذا
الفيروس الذي تسرب من المختبر كيف كيف كان
موجودا اصلا في المختبر
اذا لم يصنع اكيد دي نقطه طبعا غايه في
الاهميه ولابد من توضيحها لانه هناك
الاحتمال الوارد طبعا وده يعني ما تطرقت
اليه جريده
تسرب من المعمل هل تسرب من المعمل نتيجه
مثلا علماء جلبوا الفيروس واشتغلوا عليه
يعني الاكتشاف خصائصه وانواعه يعني طبيعه
هذا الفيروس ونتيجه قله الاجراءات
الوقائيه تسرب عن طريق المعمل باصابه احد
العلماء الذين يعملون عليه ولكن اذا كانت
هذه الفرضيه صحيحه فده معناته ان الفيروس
موجود في الطبيعه اصلا بره صحيح
بالظبط يعني للاشخاص الذين يتعاملوا مع
الحيوانات البريه ايضا وذلك يعني ما يعني
يقارب اكثر الواقع بصوره منطقيه
الاحتمالين واردين انه يكون تسرب يعني
تذكر يعني منذ سنوات منذ اواخر 2019 موضوع
كورونا يعني شغل العالم
وسويس كذلك في بشكل كبير لماذا وقتها اذكر
الايس كريم كان تحدث عن هذا الموضوع كان
يسميه بالفيروس الصيني وبانه بالفعل تسرب
من مختبر لماذا وقتها هوجمت هذه الفرضيه
هي الفرضيه هي قائمه يعني الفرضيه قائمه
ولكن يعني ممكن فعلا يكون تسرب كما ذكرنا
يعني بطريقه من الاثنين ولكن علميا كل
البيانات والتسلسل الجيني بتشير الى ان
الفيروس تركيبه الجينلن يتم التعامل معه
بطريقه او طريقه يعني اصطناعيه عن طريق
قطع او لصق كما يحدث فيه فيروسات التي يتم
تصنيعها يعني غرض الحروب البيولوجيه مثل
مثلا الجمره الخبيثه او انتركس يعني يمكن
ايجاد المناطق التي يتم ادخال او ازاله
جزء من الجينات وايضا يعني
بدراسه التسلسل او يعني اجداد
الاصول اصول هذا الفيروس يعني وجد انه
بصوره طبيعيه هناك يعني اصول تحولت منها
الفيروسات الموجوده الان فيروسات
يبقى السؤال كذلك مطروحا انه من اين جاء
هذا الفيروس اصلا للمختبر من اين جاء به
العلماء الى المختبر ومنه تسرب ونكب
العالم بعد ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد
سلمان انت استاذ علم المناعه كنت معنا
مباشره
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه مواجهه خطيره
بين طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو الامريكي
ومقاتلات صينيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في بحر الصين الجنوبي
تتزايد التوترات بين الجانبين الامريكي
والصيني على خلفيه الاحتكاك الجوي الاخير
بين مقاتله جويه امريكيه واخرى صينيه
لتنذر بصراع وشيك ومواجهه بارزه بين بكين
مدته 15 دقيقه بين مقاتله صينيه واخرى
امريكيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي بؤره
التوتر بين واشنطن
على مسافه لا تتعدى بضع مئات الاقدام حلقت
مقاتله صينيه مزوده باربعه صواريخ جو جو
قرب طائره دوريه امريكيه احتكاك كاد يشعل
مواجهه بين البلدين وهي اول حادثه بعض
المنطاد الصيني الذي اسقطته امريكا
بكين من خلال قاعده عسكريه بريه هددت
باعتراض الطائره الامريكيه في حال اخترقت
المجال الجوي الصيني بل وتوعدت باتخاذ كل
الخطوات التي تضمن عدم المساس بسيادتها
وهو ما دفع الطائره الامريكيه للتراجع بعد
التهديدات الصينيه وفق ما نقله الصحفيون
التابعون لشبكه سي ان ان كان ضمن طاقم
طائره الاستطلاع الامري
فالمواجهه بين الاسطولين الامريكي والصيني
اصبحت شبهه يوميه واكثر خطوره فقبل شهرين
فقط كادت ان تصطدم طائرتنا ملكيه بمقاتله
صينيه فوق المنطقه حينها اكد البنتاجون ان
الطائره تفادت الاصطدام بصعوبه في منطقه
تعد من اهم الطرق التجاريه في العالم من
المنظور الصيني تحركات واشنطن في المنطقه
تهدد امنها القومي وان الولايات المتحده
هي السبب وراء قضايا الامن البحري غير ان
واشنطن ترى ان رضع التحركات الصينيه هو
الحل الوحيد لخفض التصعيد
اذا كنت تعمل كثيرا لدينا خبر جيد بخصوص
ايام العمل واوقاته حيث اظهرت دراسه جديده
اجريت في المملكه المتحده نتائج مبهره
للعمل اربعه ايام فقط مقابل ثلاثه ايام
عطله في نهايه الاسبوع الدراسه التي
نشرتها شركه الابحاث البريطانيه شملت 61
شركه وحوالي 2900 عامل وخلصت الى ملاحظه
نجاح باهر في العمل بعد انخفاض الضغوط
بالنسبه للموظفين الذين حصلوا على وقت
شخصي اضافي ووجد الموظفون فرصه اكبر
للتقليل من الاجهاد وتحسين الصحه العقليه
والمزيد من ممارسه الرياضه ووقت اسهل
للنوم وقالت 56 شركه من اصل 61 كانت ضمن
هذه الدراسه قالت انها مستمره في نظام
العمل اربعه ايام في الاسبوع فيما اكدت
ثماني عشره شركه تغييرا سياستها للنظام
الجديد بشكل دائم اما المو ظفون فقال 90%
منهم انهم يرغبون في استمرار العمل باربعه
ايام اسبوعيا وافاد 55% من الموظفين
بزياده قدرتهم على العمل بعد ان حصلوا على
يوم عطله اضافي اي ثلاثه ايام في الاسبوع
اضرار كبيره سببتها العاصفه الاخيره في
كاليفورنيا لدرجه انها جرفت سيارات وطرقا
بشكل كامل نشاهد
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين وزير الخارجيه السعودي في كياب
ويلتقي زيلينسكي دعوه للحل السلمي
ومساعدات الى اوكرانيا اتفاق خفض التصعيد
في العقبه تخللته عمليه تقتل مستوطنين
وهجمات انتقاميه على بلده حوار في نابلس
لاول مره منذ عام 2011 وزير خارجيه مصر في
دمشق غدا وقرار بتسريع عوده العلاقات
تقرير امريكي رسمي يؤكد ان كورونا تسرب من
مختبر من خلال حادث وليس برنامجا عسكريا
شكرا لكم على كرم مشاهده اخبار الساعه
لهذه الليله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]